sur le champ des principes il n'y a pas
de place pour la négociation citation de
lucien bouchard ancien premier ministre
québécois c'est comme ça qu'on pourrait
définir la situation de l'accord
commercial e mercosur signé à l'été 2010
9 mais toujours pas ratifiés puisque bon
nombre de gouvernements européens dont
la france s'y sont opposés si ces fameux
principe était donc honoré on devrait
même plus en parler et pourtant le
dossier est au centre des débats de ce
30ème sommet virtuel à du mercosur ce
vendredi alors en quoi consiste
concrètement cet accord négocié depuis
plus de 20 ans eh bien il s'agit
d'établir une zone de libre échange
entre l'union européenne et le mercosur
composé de quatre pays d'amérique latine
l'argentine le brésil le paraguay et
l'uruguay
en résumé une simplification des
procédures douanières et l'élimination
des barrières tarifaires plus de 90% et
droits de douane supprimés sur les
échanges commerciaux entre les deux
rives de l'atlantique un accord qui
favoriserait les exportations
européennes d'automobiles notamment
elle met également les exportations
textiles et pharmaceutiques et qui
favoriserait dans le sens contraire elle
les importations alimentaires d'où
l'expression cars hors cause comprenez
voiture contre viande bovine ces
échanges commerciaux pourraient être
fatales pour nos éleveurs si jamais il
venait à être ratifié tant la
concurrence est déloyale en ce qui
concerne les normes environnementales
sociales ou sanitaire la compatibilité
de ce discours avec le droit du commerce
et les droits de llorente ya quand vous
voyez qu'en france on a mis un article
dans le cadre de la loi j'ai il ya un
article l'article 44 qui normalement
interdit la commercialisation de
produits ne respectant pas nos normes
la france n'arrive même pas à mettre en
application sur son territoire cet
article là et on voudrait nous expliquer
qu'on pourrait demain arrivé à imposer
des clauses dans un accord dans un
accord de libre échange entre l'europe
et le mercosur donc là aussi on sait que
voilà c'est de l'enfumage c'est pas
possible
quel est l'intérêt d'aller nous mettre
en concurrence avec ces pays là une
concurrence complètement déloyale on
n'arriverait pas résisté face à 7 face à
cette arrivée de massifs de viande
venant de
de partout sur la planète qui est donc
voilà là aussi quelle est la logique des
inquiétudes qui ne devrait plus en être
puisque la france s'est fermement opposé
à ce projet en 2019
emmanuel macron invoquant un processus
de déforestation industrialisés dans la
forêt amazonienne avait accusé son
homologue brésilien jaillir un bol sonar
ou de ne pas respecter ses engagements
climatiques et fait savoir que la france
s'opposait à l'accord et mercosur en
l'état
oui mais voilà le sujet a fait de
nouveau parler puisque les quatre
présidents du mercosur discute
actuellement de cet accord il ya
quelques mois de nouvelles négociations
ont eu lieu également l'union européenne
a proposé en janvier une déclaration
conjointe de complémentaire portant sur
des engagements en matière de
développement durable
elle vise notamment la réduction de la
déforestation de l'amazonie n'est paris
souhaite plus de garanties et non une
simple déclaration
ce n'est pas en se repliant qu'on va
s'en sortir mais nous nous satisferons
pas d'une déclaration politique sur des
engagements en matière environnementale
venant des quatre pays concernés
cela prendra beaucoup de temps la france
ne signera pas cet accord en état des
déclarations qui sont loin de rassurer
les acteurs de la société civile qui
pressentent que cet accord pourrait être
ratifié sous certaines conditions
450 associations et ong issues de
plusieurs pays ont donc décidé de se
réunir au sein de la coalition stop
c'est à mercosur l appel à travers une
déclaration commune les gouvernements de
l'union européenne
abandonner purement et simplement cet
accord cet accord va aggraver la
destruction et l'effondrement de la
biodiversité de l'amazonie du cerrado et
du grande cas qu en raison de la hausse
des quotas d'importation de bétail et
d'éthanol vers l'europe
perpétuant un modèle agricole
extractiviste fondée sur le surpâturage
l'expansion de l'élevage intensif avec
des parcs d'engraissement pour le bétail
et des monocultures dépendante des
pesticides et produits chimiques les
signataires de cette déclaration
craignent que le gouvernement français
change de cap
on reproche notamment à la france de ne
pas renoncer au texte ce qui pourrait
influencer les autres pays
européen encore réticents comme
l'allemagne à reconsidérer cet accord
reste à savoir si l'environnement
triomphera pour une fois sur le
capitalisme à outrance